have check who is going to be responding
on behalf of the navalny foundation
3 27 followed by 139
Daniel over here congratulations thank
you Shelby remind you of the Forum and
the band and Dylan
I asked you before what you wanted to
tell the world because this was a unique
situation you were in maybe never an
audience like this to hear your words
what do you hope the world heard from
you and from the wife of Alexei navalny
I want the world to remember that right
now Alexei navalny is languishing in
prison he is the only prisoner who's
removed from the general prison
population in the Russian penal system
he is in Perpetual solitary confinement
and the reason he is in such abhorrent
conditions is because he is the number
one oppositionist to this war in Russia
he is the one guy who opposes Putin's
brutal war in Ukraine and that's why he
is in solitary confinement I want to
make sure the world doesn't forget about
our guy I want to make sure that navalny
gets out of prison one day survives this
ordeal his wife and children want him
back navalny should be freed that's
where I want the world to remember
tonight
number 139
hi good evening my name is stanislava
from Nova TV Bulgaria I just want to say
that we're extremely proud of Christo I
met him yesterday and I told him that
myself but I'm very happy for all of you
guys
um my question is to Daniel and Maria
um how important was Christo's
investigation to get all the way up here
to the stage of the Oscars well from my
perspective it was just pivotal I
remember the moment when Christo walked
in and he said I think I have a lead
into who tried to poison navalny and it
was as remarkable then as it sounds now
and it was really his invest
investigative pedigree that put us on
the path to making this film and of
course he worked in concert with Maria
so I'll let her speak to him yes I was
very impressed with both of you working
together thank you um I'll be very sure
when navalny was still in coma after the
poisoning
um I was sitting there and just thinking
I will probably dedicate my entire life
to trying to figure out who poisoned him
it will take me years maybe decades but
I will find the trees thanks to Krista
it took us two weeks
thank you
all right and next up we have number one
eight four
I Eli Glasser from CBC news
congratulations Eli from CBC what's up
hey Daniel great evening for you I want
you to take us back to that amazing
moment where you get the poisoner on the
phone and the camera is rolling and
correct me if I'm wrong you don't
understand Russian right not a word no
so
take me into your head as you know
something is occurring and it seems
significant but you don't know and then
like 14 minutes of what
well first and foremost we were shooting
for a long time that morning it was
early I was exhausted I was would have
been very pleased if we could have just
wrapped up and gone back to bed I had no
expectation Eli that anything meaningful
would have happened that morning and
then on one particular call
I remember clocking that the
conversation was progressing longer than
any of the others had
and then there's this moment in the film
that I clocked in real time where
Maria's jaw unhinges and hits the floor
and although I don't speak a word of
Russian I knew exactly what was
happening and I figured we'd get five
minutes a bolt of lightning ran up and
down my spine I made sure the camera was
in Focus I made sure we had enough space
on the hard drives and I just kept
filming unbeknownst to me at the time
that call went on for 50 minutes and
that guy gave a full confession a
minute-by-minute litigation of exactly
how this poisoning went down
and it was stunning and surreal it sort
of feels like this moment now actually
there's a full circle Miss to that phone
call to standing on the stage
followed by two
and also um if you are called to be next
if you can keep your number up while the
number before you is asking their
question that helps our team find you to
give you your microphone and we have a
whole Squad up here so if anyone has any
questions from anyone else
hi I'm Janet Walker from
hotlifestyle.com uh what is uh his
condition right now and do you expect
him to be released Maria do you want to
speak to Alexa's current condition
um for the last five months he has been
in a solitary confinement uh we're
talking about a cell which is 6 by 11
feet large and
um there's barely anything there's a
tiny little window
um one chair one little table and a bed
that is being chained up to the wall
every day at 5am and chained down at 9
00 PM so he cannot use it during the day
um he is unwell in terms of health and I
don't like to deliver this sort of news
but that's that's true uh due to the
fact that he's in a solitary confinement
he's on the strict regime he is not
allowed to
um have such basic things yes I don't
know like books or calls to his family
and he hasn't seen he his family members
for almost a year which is completely
illegal so
um I classify his present conditions as
torture that isn't another word
um and we have two six six up next yes
so um many congratulations on your win
so on your speech you talked about
dictatorships and uh political prisoners
I'm from Iran and my outlet is Iran
International TV based on London so as
you know we have a the same enemy the
dictators are the same they're doing the
same things Islamic Republic sending
drones to kill people in Ukraine and
um how is it important to these nations
to be United against the same dictators
do you want anyone specifically to
answer that
um just you General
speech you talk about political prison
sure yeah that was very uh interesting
to me we made our film about the leader
of the Russian opposition and his
mission
his quest to install democracy a
democratic tradition in Russia but this
film was not just for Russians this film
worked for people all over the world who
are living in a context where the tides
of authoritarianism come in and come out
and come in and come out
and what we want our film to remind the
world is that we all have to be on guard
for the values that we
believe in
and the lives that we want to live and
those are democratic values and that's
what navalny is fighting for
and I think that this film and this win
is in solidarity and in support of not
just Alexa navalny but of political
prisoners around the world especially
including the struggle for freedom in
Iran
and it's very meaningful for me that I
get to deliver that message on behalf of
the entire team and on behalf of
navalny's family
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations thank you thank you